well either love wall-e or actually I
can't think of anyone that hates wall-e
but there are some people who are
indifferent to it bottom line there
seems to be these two camps in terms of
talking about the movie those who love
the movie from beginning to end and
those who like the first half but don't
really like the second half that much
and sad to say I'm kind of in that
second boat I don't hate it it's just
after the first tactic okay let's go
ahead and take a look at it it's the
future and mankind has abandoned earth
why because we polluted it with so much
garbage and everything else that nothing
can actually live there
they start building these robots to try
and clean up all the garbage but they
all eventually died out that is except
for one that of course is wall-e despite
the fact that he's really the only
survivor left on earth he still
continues on with his everyday job he
does have a personality though including
being incredibly lonely kind of a
hopeless romantic and an absolute fanboy
for hello dolly things start to change
though when another robot named Eve
approaches the planet at first she seems
very destructive but wall-e Maj is to
find a way into her heart and form a
strong friendship but their friendship
has to be put on hold when she discovers
a plant growing she takes this back to
where mankind is now living on the sort
of space cruise where mankind has now
grown very accustomed to being fat and
lazy and just letting technology do all
the work for him look they'll even have
to use their legs anymore wall-e comes
along and that's a hair-raising
adventure to see who can get the plan to
humanity first and show that earth is
still an inhabitable planet you can
probably guess which halves people seem
to like or dislike with this movie a lot
of people seem to really enjoy the first
half where there's little to no dialogue
a lot of atmosphere a lot of quiet
moments and all we have to focus on is
the friendship / romance of these two
machines it's very slow and I think a
lot of people thought they'd be bored by
it but actually this is the part that
most people seem to enjoy the most the
second half I don't think goes down hill
it just isn't as good as the first half
we see what mankind is up to we see
they're not totally beyond hope that
they do in fact have some likability and
yeah we want to see them return to Earth
and repopulate the species again
kiss my major issues with the second
half is one we know what the lesson is
gonna be help we know what the lesson is
in the first second of the movie it's a
cautionary tale about the future and
technology and pollution and yeah it's
good and it was much more powerful we
didn't hammer it in the environment is
all you need my second issue is that the
world that they create for Humanity is
not all that interesting and I don't
know why the ship should be really cool
with all the high-tech gadgets and
technology and all the funny little
jokes they have going on and they're by
no means awful it's just not Pixar's a
game joke material the humans all sort
of look the same and act the same a lot
of the other robots aren't really that
memorable the commentary is pretty clear
and yeah is it awful no I think a lot of
people just thought after that first
half there was something even stronger
than was building up to like an even
bigger conspiracy and there is one sort
of the ship's computer deserve a Hal
9000 it doesn't want humanity to return
but there's nothing that much to it
I think a lot of people would have been
happier if they either just kept it on
earth the whole time if humanity was
sort of the great mystery or maybe if
the second half was like a space
adventure where they'd go through all
sorts of different worlds and planets
and galaxies and I don't know just
something a little stronger than this
but honestly I think it's just the lilo
and stitch effect it's not that one part
is necessarily bad it's just that one
part was so unbelievably good it
overshadows the other half some points
are where like I don't know why they
have live-action people at some times
and then computer-generated ones at
others they don't try to make the CG
people look like real people so it's
kind of distracting I also never got how
if Eve is supposed to be the machine
that goes down and tries to find life
that delicate life that she needs to
protect how come she keeps blowing up
everything like if anything moves she
just destroys it is that kind of going
against what the mission is well outside
of that I think wall-e is a very
enjoyable picture I think it could have
been an unbelievable film if it kept the
tone it had in the first half but it's
still smart enough and it still has some
creativity and it still keeps your
interest so I like the film I don't know
if I see it that many times again but I
think it was enjoyable once it has some
entertaining as well as mature moments
for kids and it has some great
atmosphere for adults and in my opinion
that's more than enough to recommend